The next concept that you need to understand is the concept of classes. Look at
these dates. Here we have a date, the date of the Mariner 4 spacecraft launch,
another date that happens to be the inauguration of FD Roosevelt. And a third
date, the date of the first lunar landing. Now, all of these objects have
something in common. They all day objects. In Java, objects that have common
behavior are collected into classes. So the day class is the class that
contains all of the day objects. And the reason you want to know about this is
when you want to find out something about how days work. You will want to look
at the documentation of the day class. It tells you what everyday object it is.
Let me give you another example of a class. Here is a string object, and
another, and another. All these string objects have something in common. They
all have the same behavior. And in Java, the String class defines what their
common behavior is. You will learn a lot more about the String class in this
lesson. Let's go back to our day class for a minute, and think a bit more what
it means for objects to have common behavior. It means that they can all do the
same kinds of things. Like what can they do? As you've seen when you played
with days and BlueJ, any day object let's you get the month, get the year or add
days to itself. These actions are called the Methods of the Day class. They are
the kinds of things that you can apply to day objects to achieve some kind of
functionality. The word method, sounds a bit strange at first, and you should
just think of it as terminology. It's just where one calls the actions that you
can apply to any of the day objects.